Jesus is divine, Muhammad is irrelevant.
Denies his divinity. Quran 5:75, the
Messiah son of Mary was only a
messenger. It denies his sonship.
>> Ben Shapiro, you know very well our
theologies are more aligned and you know
why you're defending the son of God and
Jesus God etc. Your theology not only
disregards that, insults it.
>> Then not only will you agree that
everything I said is not disrespectful,
but you'll actually abandon your beliefs
in Jesus because you'll see that it's
all man-made uh foolishness.
>> Just to explain the gratitude and the
happiness that this
brother of ours is facing. Just 10
minutes ago he couldn't stand.
Alhamdulillah through your donations to
Walk Forever, today not only is he
standing, but he has a smile on his
face. Jazakallahu khairan to each and
every one of you. You dignified our
brother, our father from Gaza.
Donate to Walk Forever and help change
lives today.
>> Today's video will be a Muslim, a
Christian, Candace Owens, and a Jew,
which is Ben Shapiro. More like a
Zionist Jew who goes against anything
the everything the the book teaches, you
know. They were exiled from their lands.
They're like, "No, we're going to
reverse engineer and go back there and
ride it ride it right." Forget it,
today's not about that. Today we're
going to be watching a video of Candace
Owens reciting the Quran and then we're
going to go to Ben Shapiro being upset
that the whole world has woken up to the
reality of the Zionist and everything
that they are trying to do to reverse
engineer their fake Messiah, the Dajjal,
the Antichrist, to come back because
they rejected Jesus. And because they
rejected Jesus, this is a punishment
from God Almighty onto them. And the
real Jews believe in this, that's why
they believe they should be in exile.
Anyways, here is what Ben Shapiro had to
say and then we're going to go to how
Candace Owens recites how the Quran and
this actually destroys and dismantles
the Islamic dilemma. How? Because like
no logic,
admitted the
hijab that the Quran came to correct the
narrative, and this is one of the
examples of that.
>> Jesus is divine, Muhammad is irrelevant.
Denies his divinity. Quran 5:75, "The
Messiah, son of Mary, was only a
messenger." It denies his sonship. Quran
19:35, "It is not befitting for Allah to
take a son." It denies his crucifixion.
"They did not kill him, nor crucify him,
but it was made to appear so."
So, according to Baroumi, again, he's a
Christian who was a Muslim. The Quran
preserves Jesus only in order to negate
him.
He's a shell and an empty to substance.
The Jesus of Islam is not the eternal
son of God, not the word made flesh, not
the crucified and risen Lord. He's an
anti-Jesus, retained only to erase the
true one. Jesus is divine, Muhammad is
irrelevant.
If Jesus is the son of God, Muhammad's
message collapses. The Quran must
therefore silence the real Christ in
order to establish Muhammad's authority.
>> Okay, there you go. So, in a nutshell,
there you can see the attempt um
the attempt of Ben Shapiro of his most
his subscriber base by 70 80%. Uh Subhan
Allah, he's now upset that the
Christians and the Muslims are woken up
to their real Well, the Muslims have
been awake, but the Christians have
woken up like Candace Owens, Tucker
Carlson,
uh Megan Kelly, if that's her name is,
and the rest who have woken up and said,
"Hold on a second, we've been sold a big
fat lie." And he's upset, so he's like,
"No, no, no, we need to cause more
division because we need you Muslims and
Christians to fight each other, both you
goyims, okay? Yes, both you goyims, so
we can be uh the the building the new uh
greater Israel uh plan. Yes, okay, I'm
waiting for their fake Messiah." And
here is before we delve into the and
dive into it, inshallah, here is what uh
um Candace Owens reads from the Quran,
and the Quran came to honor and defend
the honor of Mary and Jesus, and even
Suleiman, Solomon. Yes, and many other
prophets and Lot who were being
described as doing vicious, vile things
in the Bible. The Quran came to correct
that narrative, which gives a big middle
finger an intellectual middle finger to
No who has no logic, uh
about the Quran, affirming the
scripture. But, let's watch what Candace
Owens have to say.
>> Radical right writes, "Thank you very
much for that donation. Um hi, American
Muslim fan here. In the spirit of
friendship between our faiths, here is
an excerpt from the Quran about Jesus
who speaking as a baby to defend Mary's
honor said, 'I am the servant of God. He
has given me the scripture and made me a
prophet, and he has made me blessed
wherever I am. God is my Lord and your
Lord, so worship him.'"
I think all of us are are realizing uh
the tremendous need for true faith right
now, and I had
sort of tweeted
a couple of days ago that you can sense
a [__] in the armor
of deception. Like, we're learning a lot
about how a lot of of money has been put
behind these Judeo-Christian programs,
which was something that I would speak
about with Charlie because he was, in
fact, very interested in Catholicism. Uh
and so, it is interesting to see that. I
I do think the evangelical community is
feeling that, and let me know if you
agree that people are starting to wonder
like, "Why does my pastor" and again,
it's not every pastor, but it's too many
pastors get up on a stage and preach
about Megyn Kelly and Tucker Carlson.
That is leading to broader questions.
And I think in the end, all of this is
good. Like, the the topic of faith being
at the forefront of our minds worldwide
is good.
>> That's good. So, in a nutshell, you can
see that both the the Judeo-Christian
values, which is absolutely nonsense,
the Christians are basically aiding
Israel and the Jews. The Christians hate
Jews. Why? Because they believe that
they killed their God.
>> Christians in Jerusalem's Old City say
they are often harassed, spit on, and
even physically attacked by religious
Jewish youth.
>> I view this phenomenon as extreme and
unacceptable in any shape or form. This
phenomenon needs to be uprooted.
>> Earlier incidents include the
desecration of a Protestant cemetery on
Mount Zion, an attack on international
Christians during a day of prayer for
Jerusalem, and harassment at a Messianic
concert in Jerusalem.
>> And for many reasons that Jews believe
that Jesus
was a a fake Messiah. Yes, that he's
burning his own feces. His mother is an
adulterer. That's the reason the Quran
came to honor and reverse this and
defend the honor of Mary and Jesus. And
the Christians are aiding that at the
they have a plan. They have a little
sneaky plan there against the Jews. They
basically like, "Let's support Israel
cuz when the real Jew comes, he's going
to mass when the real Jesus comes, he's
going to mass the Jews." Okay. So,
they're doing they're plotting against
each other. Okay. That's why they
support him. Not that they love them,
but again, they're doing it at the cost
of going against their faith. Unless
unlike people like Candace Owens, Tucker
Carlson, and Megan Kelly who are waking
up and saying, "No, this is not
Christian values of to see a genocide
that's happening." Now, let's go to a
rabbi. This rabbi is going to break down
to us what they actually believe about
Jesus. So, the Quran came down. This is
an evidence, as you can see, that
debunks Islamic dilemma, which is
it's just it's just a weak argument.
Yes, that the Quran came down to correct
these narratives. Not only that, the
Quran is the only scripture that
fulfills this. When Jesus says in the
Bible, "I have many things to say unto
you, but you cannot bear them now. For
he when the spirit of truth shall come,
he will guide you unto all truth. He
shall not speak of himself. As he hears,
he shall speak." I wonder who's that
talking about. "And he shall glorify
me." Keep telling me all. He he he he he
he he. He's talking about a person.
Okay. And when it comes with the truth,
yes. And he says, "He shall glorify me."
Now, let's put Islam to a side. Let's
look at Judaism,
well,
Hinduism, Sikhism, Buddhism, and all
those other faiths. Which religion
glorifies Jesus?
Islam is the only one that glorifies
Jesus, and it's a tenant of our faith to
believe that Jesus is
the Messiah, a true prophet, his second
coming, etc. And it's so desperate of
Ben Shapiro trying to show that we don't
really glorify Jesus. No, we believe we
have the real Jesus. The Jesus that says
in the Bible that on that day many will
say to me, "Lord, Lord, did we not
prophesy in thy name and in thy name
cast out demons?" Who cast out in the
name in the name demons out in the name
of Jesus and who prophesies in his name?
The Christians. Well, Jesus will say to
them on that day, "Get away from me, you
adulterers or evil generation. I do not
know you." And that's what Allah says in
the Quran, "On that day when Allah asked
Mary and Jesus, did you tell them to
worship you and your mother besides me?"
He said, "Oh my Lord, you know what's
inside my heart and I do not know what's
in yours." Okay, that I did not say such
a thing. That's the reason why Jesus
coming. So, when Christians come and
say, "Oh, why is Jesus coming but not
Muhammad, peace be upon him?" It's
because you guys there's two
main reasons.
Jews rejected him and insulted him. The
Christians exalted him to a level that
made him God. Islam came with a balance.
So, Jesus going to come back and on that
day everyone's going to believe that he
is the Messiah and everyone's going to
believe that he's not God. He's going to
come to claim to the Jews that he was
the Messiah and
you know, defend his mother like he did
in the Quran. And secondly, to break the
cross and say I never told you to
worship me.
>> So, you have to understand that the
Torah itself commands us
to mock idolatry.
And believing that something else other
than God of Israel is God is idolatry.
If you actually watch my lectures about
the New Testament, then not only will
you agree that everything I said is not
disrespectful, but you'll actually
abandon your beliefs in Jesus because
you'll see that it's all man-made
foolishness and heresy and idolatry.
>> So, the rabbi there by Yusuf Abrom
Sisters explains you what they actually
believe. So, this reminds me Ben Shapiro
reminds me of the the Jews at the time
and the Jews were not the same. There
were Jews who were observant Abdallah
ibn Salam, if I'm not mistaken, who
became a Muslim and his Look look at
look at the hypocrisy that they had. So,
not all Jews the real Jews who followed
Islam became Muslims. Alhamdulillah.
Yes, okay. And
so, you can see subhanallah that they
when they met the pagan Arabs that them
they were that they were persecuting the
Muslims.
When the Jews met them at that time Banu
Qurayza, Banu
Banu Nadir, and Banu Qaynuqa, when they
met them, they asked that the pagan
Arabs asked them, "Whose religion is
better?" They said, "Your religion is
better."
What the hell are you talking about?
Their religion is better? Ben Shapiro,
you know very well our theology is more
aligned. And you know why you're
defending the son of God and Jesus God
etc. Your theology only disregards that,
insults it. Okay? And the Jews at the
time of Medina the Prophet Muhammad they
did the same thing. They said, "Your
religion is better than Muhammad's."
Subhanallah, imagine that. Just so they
reject the truth. So much so, wallahi,
one of the Prophet's wives, I forgot her
name, who was
when the Battle of Khaybar happened,
yes? They were captured. Subhanallah,
he's
the woman who came to the Prophet's wife
the Prophet's
wife or mother. And she said that when
my dad and my uncle saw you, they came
back like they like they're in
nightmare. Like like they saw a ghost.
And they said, "Is it really him?"
Yes, he said, "By Allah, it is him. But
we will reject him till the day we die."
Why? Because he's not a Jew.
Can you make that Can you Can you
imagine that? This is the level they go
for because they are seeing that the
Christians and the Muslims are waking up
to the deception of these Zionist Jews.
Yes, the Zionist Jews. And that's all I
have to say brothers and sisters, the
Quran came to honor and preserve Jesus
subhanallah dignity and honor and his
mother. And alhamdulillah this not only
debunks Islamic dilemma and also shows
you that level-headed true Christians
like Candace Owens, they're not the same
like no logic and April well, April we
have to put his wife in the job for
somebody and donations. Okay? And the
rest. These are true Christians.
Subhanallah. That's all I have to say
brothers and sisters. Inshallah, may
Allah allow us uh to follow and join the
armies of Jesus against the Antichrist.
Till next time, assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh. If you are
Christian watching this,
look into what we actually believe in
him and subhanallah, you will see that
you will find the true Jesus in Islam.
Goodbye.